quote
sur le terrain tous les jours
je fais des repérages koji tu prends des
notes pour un coût que je fais je
n'imagine 30
y a que ça qui me fait bander
c'est gagner j'en ferais pas 39
rencontres n'ont pas heureux noah qui
s'est pointé chez ta soeur est moi qui
ai tué en trois jours soit 8 août en fin
mai
des gâteaux oprah cargo frost 80 kilos
d'héroïne
tu fais ça en est quitte par le kof je
parle avec tous m'ont pas du goût du
moment que ça rapporte on va braquer des
charges et moyens afin de nous mêmes on
est des bras tu remets pas des durs
c'est pas des convoyeurs que tu vas
bretons nous a encore entraîner dans
cette histoire c'est pas